but despite the media's deceptive
coverage Biden continues to struggle in
the polls especially among working class
African-American and Latino voters
joining us now with analysis outnumbered
co-host Kaylee mcenany and Fox News
contributor Ari Fleischer let me let me
let me ask this because I think this is
important Kelly I'll start with you it's
obvious the brand was Joe
Joe the LIE isn't just once it was a
repeated lie as a candidate and as
president never spoke to Hunter brother
or anybody about foreign business deals
he's up to his eyeballs in it Hunter has
no experience he's an addict at the time
by his own admission and he's taking in
millions of dollars from some of our
largest geopolitical foes so explain to
me what did he do for that money what
did the grandchildren do for the money
that was funneled to them
well Hunter Biden could have offered
finger paints that he did with his crack
pipe which we know go for anywhere from
five hundred thousand dollars and
upwards
um but outside of that what was he
offering brisma of course Sean you state
the obvious
um ahead of that meeting there's a
meeting that sticks out to me it's the
Dubai meeting at the Four Seasons this
is with Charisma Executives he's sitting
there Devin Archer testified to this and
there had been multiple pressure emails
sent to Hunter Biden pressure to get
Victor shoken fired the prosecutor
looking into Prisma Devon Archer wasn't
present for the conversation but we know
Hunter Biden dialed up his father the
vice president puts him on speakerphone
five days later Joe Biden then goes to
Ukraine where he delivers a speech about
guess what uh digging into corruption in
Ukraine involving the prosecutor Victor
shulkin who we know goes on to be fired
coincidence I'll leave that to you all
but doesn't seem like much of a
coincidence to me
all these countries all this money no
experience admitted addict at the time
Ari Fleischer what are we looking at
it's pedaling it's it's pretty plain and
clear but there's a level of corruption
too and it's a bribery Sean is it
bribery well it depends on where it very
well may be we have to find out if Joe
Biden got any of this money as emails
indicate that the money that went to
Hunter was split with his father and
that Joe Biden uh expenses were paid by
his son hunter or his brother then of
course it's bribery
just to be clear Sean hold on a second
but wait that's important even without
even without it being any money reaching
Joe Biden it was an act of corruption
for Joe Biden not to get put on those
phone calls by his son Joe Biden got
himself on those phone calls no one made
him do it he voluntarily got on those
calls as the vice president to influence
the partners making business decisions
that resulted in Hunter getting money
that's an act of corruption by an
elected official regardless of whether
he got money now if you got money it's
even worse but what he did in and of
itself that we already know about is an
act of corruption 20 times
but the bribery statue what I was going
to tell you is if if an elected official
takes an official action that benefits a
family member or enriches a family
member that's that that fits the statute
that would be guilty here's the question
where's the media Kaylee mcenany
great question I mean they've covered
the Trump indictments over a 39-day
period according to NewsBusters for 500
plus minutes precisely zero minutes on
Devon archer in the Biden corruption
scandals you know this is a big deal
Sean even if you know let's say you're
delusional in the liberal media which we
know they all are even if you don't
believe Joe Biden said anything on these
calls they discussed the weather we all
know that's improbable you'd have to be
an idiot to believe that but let's say
you believe all of that and the least we
know Joe Biden lied he said he never
spoke to his son uh now he's moved the
needle I never was in business with my
son we know that those are not true now
he lied and the Press won't cover it is
a total and blatant cover-up it is
medium malpractice Ari will the media be
forced to cover this as more gets
revealed every day
well I think if they begin an
impeachment inquiry as Speaker McCarthy
talked about then they have no choice
but they're going to cover it in a
slanted negative biased way the deck is
stacked and we all know it
all right thank you Ari thank you Kaylee
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else